never gets you you wonder why America
the Heartland doesn't think that you
have their best interests at heart
because a nutless monkey would be more
effective at putting America perky I
think this actually is already censored
you let me kind of make some points as
to why and you guys can let me know
where you think I'm wrong yeah you can
let me know as you very often do the
media has been trying to claim that he's
been terrible at his job okay
but Donald Trump's overall approval
rating and by the way this is where
polls matter not like when Bernie
Sanders says look at Venice look at the
news will would they prefer their health
care so they do in Cuba a different deal
but they die so this is what this is
what polls matter because Donald Trump
emits a crisis and this is kind of
important because you see this quite a
bit historically it's a good indicator
60% of Americans actually approve of his
response to coronavirus his recent
approval rating with that Gallup risen
from 44 to 49 percent yeah Wow right
who'll Americans rate the worst right
now by the way the the fake fake lying
news media that's what they rate as the
worst aspect of American culture second
worst is late night hosts broadcasting
from their bathroom without a lavalier
mic that's up there we get it it's raw
it's organic Samantha bee and Jimmy
Kimmel but can't you just take a portion
of the 12 million salary and just get a
rogue mic you were wearing a suit in a
bathtub so do that just do something
this is and this is also by the way why
why they want to lean on YouTube right
Vox NBC Universal they realize they
can't compete when they start putting
this content no one wants to watch Seth
Meyers in his hallway not more than once
at the very least yeah right here's a
point
okay so travel bands to answer your
question that's - I don't know that
President Trump has done a whole lot
differently than any other president
would I think there's a limited amount
of control that you have the CDC doesn't
really have anything SS airily to do
with Trump they sort of operate
independently and we didn't have the
right information from China the World
Health Organization did not declare it a
crisis or a pandemic until March 12th so
I to be clear I know everyone's trying
to score political points I can't say
that Donald Trump has done everything
right or differently than another
president but Johnny boy who had the
horrible idea of the Schindler's List
parody
right here I do know one thing that
President Trump has specifically done
differently than all other leaders and
that's his travel ban from China he's
big Donald Trump banned it early they
didn't do that elsewhere at the same
they didn't go with the same vigor you
should say and we can compare that
directly with his competitor in a
general election
Joe dementia Biden who claimed that the
travel ban was xenophobic so this is
remarkable to me even if everything else
from President Trump were terrible was
absolutely let's say he handled
everything as poorly as can be he's
still not as bad as Joe Biden they put
up someone in the general if I'm Donald
Trump and I go into this general
election as the debate with Joe Biden
the height and he says or was enough of
a response
I just coach Donald Trump say all right
let it fly well listen i put the bin and
travel from china you said it was racist
so wet
when would you put travel restrictions
on china Joe and he won't people to
answer probably you know forget where he
is for a little if you met he's
back-to-back competitors so far gonna be
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden like the
two right weakest people to put up
against anyone yeah well especially
though on the coronavirus another word
they he has no leg to stand on on what
will be the hot-button issue here
absolutely if you were just some random
recession or something that happen they
could try and atribute it to policy
right right it was this it's clear as
day Donald Trump did something proactive
you accuse him of racism and by the way
Biden was just following lockstep with
the media they claimed it was
nonsensical an emotional reaction this
is from Fox New York Times they also
said that we shouldn't really worry
about the coronavirus that was less than
the flu but now interact like that's
just a right wing talking point we got
it from you
one of Italy's wasn't one of Italy's a
viral adjust he he he said when I'm
responding the outbreak that the fear of
the political fallout from enacting a
travel ban made the pandemic much worse
in Italy this is what he said now the
American media was saying no no don't
listen to that guy who works in Italian
government it has nothing to do with
open borders we are at a point where
political correctness
could quite literally be killing people
LGBTQA AI and people died that's the
point here hands up don't shoot
I don't I mean no that's this is an
actual thing you don't ban travel from
China where the virus originated people
will die yeah
back to like our definition of political
correctness is different than the
original right the original is from
Marxist states where and and this is
very specific where the Chinese
government they decided the politically
correct thing for doctors to do is deny
that there was a virus yeah so this is
legitimately this entire thing is
actually an extension of political
correctness right yeah and it's
dangerous it's not without consequences
people think it's well I'm being nice
because I'm not offending people there's
been obviously a multi-faceted approach
from Korres Donald Trump if this is one
thing that you can say singularly unique
in comparison to whether it's Biden or
Bernie but it seems like the candidate
will obviously be Biden unless you know
they don't have enough smelling salts
but the point is I think that's a that's
a stark contrast
kudus it Joe Biden is really unwell he
is not doing well at all this this week
yet a series of disastrous media
appearances first I think we have this
the one with a failed teleprompter on a
live stream watch said beefed up the
number of responders dealing with the
crush knees crushing cases and we are
well let me let me go the second thing
president must use a defense production
act the second thing no Joe what's the
second thing what I stop and motion
there he looks like he's checking
someone for testicular cancer you have
to be to keep putting him out there in
that combine oh yeah really asking
seriously it's not a punchline no
somebody's you just didn't have someone
waving it off like stop but not off the
fight his family needs to be there with
a towel and throw the towel it's over
for John it's very fitting because Putin
will kill him break it the symbolism is
everywhere
there went to the fist bump though
because six feet we understand that so
he then went on the view and the
responses they weren't they were not at
all coherent in hot topics we just about
Trump saying the government would
reassess the recommended period for
keeping businesses shut and people at
home
are you at all concerned as Trump said
that we cannot let the Cure be worse
than the problem itself we have to take
care of the cure that will make the
problem worse no matter what I don't
want to be that guy of the gotcha in his
defense he didn't misspeak
see I get it all confuse I thought I was
taking care of the Smiths yeah they're
almost a ninja
perhaps Joy Division this very sad lady
to throw in the towel so let's get back
to coronavirus cuz that's what we care
about right now the democrats offices
have been blocking you know the relief
bill telling there's a stimulus bill
they blocked the bill from the GOP
ministry early on with I think was it
1400 pages this bill do we know how many
pages internet keeps changing by the day
they came would you have to pass it yeah
then you can for you good really very
counter I think had 14-under pain and it
contained all sorts of ridiculous crap
that had nothing to do with the
coronavirus I'm sure you've heard of
this if you haven't there's thirty five
million in funding for the JFK
Performing Arts Center 90 million for an
HIV program 300 million for migration
and Refugee assistance Green New Deal's
these style requirements for carbon
emissions listen over 3.2 million
Americans just filed for unemployment
okay and the Democrats are demanding 300
million for illegal immigrants and
refugees yeah you wonder why America the
Heartland doesn't think that you have
their best interests at heart because a
nutless monkey would be more effective
at putting America perky I trust Joe
Biden's teleprompter more than I trusted
DMC for the United States right now
there are a lot of things that I trust
more than dancing namely all of them
here's another thing this was a big deal
and it may seem inconsequential
but I think to go back to your point I
think this is why Americans think that
Donald Trump is doing a better job
handling this and they if it were just
in a vacuum Donald Trump oh we approve a
rallying around the leader that wouldn't
explain the distrust of the media yeah
that tells me there's a conflict that
tells me that to most Americans
including Democrats there's kind of a
hero and a villain here yeah and a big
part of that was of course if you
haven't been following it and we have
the Chinese virus controversy
we continue our relentless effort to
defeat the Chinese virus by using this
injury
mr. it okay it comes from China that's
why each other
no China tried to say at one point maybe
this stuff now that it was caused by
American soldiers that can't happen it's
not gonna happen
not as long as I'm president it comes
from China I think some important
developments in our war against the
Chinese virus china Jetta if you're
gonna fix a problem you need to speak
truth yes you need to write it obvious
kated between behind this all this
political correctness and you have to
speak truth and what it is it came from
China that's where yes it mad why is
Trump saying Chinese virus valuable it's
not just because it offends all the
right people for the same reason that
bonus instituting a travel ban from
China was valuable for the same reason
that trumps brass pendulous sack in
comparison not the Biden's shriveled
demented Raisinets is valuable he's not
allowing political correctness to
dictate policy at best for Americans
also I'll tell you why Chinese virus is
important and you see this a lot with
all of these right and you see it even
in the Christian community and let's
committed that the virtue sin won't come
you like we should be nicer no you know
why Chinese virus is important because a
communist regime who tried to blame this
virus on our American troops doesn't get
to rewrite history
by the way sign up for a mug Club this
month the promo code is quarantine were
given away everything +3 morning shows
you know $69 you get $30 off hit the
notification bell if you're on YouTube
and you are not subscribed yet because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
yeah also crowd a bit subscribe and hey
look it looks to string from his mug go
to him to go back to the point of the
media this is something that's really
important to me I don't know how how
more clearly we could see the media
overreach
right now when they start blank blaming
Donald Trump for people eating koi pond
cleaner when I saw the story I was like
no they're not they're not gonna jump on
this yeah
there's no way that they lack the
self-awareness to blame Donald Trump
read for simpletons for Mongoloids
drinking koi pond cleaner mmm let me
just give you a rapid-fire recap as to
all of their all of the dishonesty here
so somebody probably heard Trump
disbanded the pandemic that pandemic
unit there at the the CT was at CDC or
the White House NHS actually he just can
just condensed it with other units that
the expertise could be pulled it was
actually decision to make government
more effective and efficient not desi
they try to say that Trump cut CDC
funding reducing the outreach by one of
it from 49 countries to 10 including
cutting their work in China the truth is
it wasn't a direct cut it was a
depletion of previously allocated funds
and the CDC got that money from
elsewhere so it's a wash who cares and
the media tried to say that Trump of
course called the coronavirus a hoax
know what you say what the Democrats
pinning the blame on his administration
was a hoax and of course don't forget
the fish tank cleaner but we all
understand that one that one's really
stupid it's fun to address but I don't
want to go over it here's the deal after
years years of the anti-trump net the
Russian collusion the you Cannes quid
pro quo can the general public can how
can they trust the media at all if you
never heard them say one good thing
about President Trump and now they're
saying that he's handling the outbreak
poorly when in fact it was the New York
Times the media who downplayed it but
you said there were prostitutes peeing
on the fur mica you said is incorrect
why would they trust you now right what
do you think he's the other thing that's
rallying behind I do think that I think
this is a good case here I mean and you
see this occasionally from media members
when they actually will acknowledge
something the daily that New York Times
podcast which is basically 30 minutes of
them destroying Trump everyday in their
minds no I don't yeah I so I with my
compromised immune system that's a B C
I'm susceptible to ear a yeah they had
Maggie Haberman on who was kind of
flipped in fake Gyllenhaal's ugly sister
yes exactly shows up in a sit on the big
screen I make an audible I think that's
everybody so she said she admitted she
said you know what early on in this
situation Trump banned flights from
China he was called racist he was called
xenophobic and it turned out that it was
a good move and it was a big move at the
time yeah now they wrap that in
thirty minutes of criticism but at least
if they will acknowledge basic truths
it'll least give us a chance to
understand and listen to the criticism
right they're so unwilling cuz they're
so obsessed with this guy yeah then you
own ormally won't even give him a point
into his favor no matter what happens
right yeah I think it's a real problem
by the way um this is something too they
complain about the Republican bill we've
heard about this go back and forth all
week we'll talk about it more next week
look the morning show will be watching
CNN in line fact-checking so it'll be a
little different guests it'll be more
like a podcast radio show less late
night II I guess so we'll be able to
talk more in depth about the bill but
initially the left's complain that the
Republican bill would allow hospitals
this was a big thing that they would
allow elective procedures to be put on
hold to make room for corona patients
that included abortions right so here's
the deal both sides have accused the
other side of playing politics with this
bill you're trying to fit this in and
you're trying to earmark this and okay
all right let's assume that that is true
because it is true both sides are trying
to play a little bit of political
football right right now they're trying
to shoehorn their crap in all right
let's assume all of that is true what
would be more relevant to a bill
exclusively designed to curb the
coronavirus and hopefully its economic
ripple effect and devastation helping
hospitals alleviate their workload by
holding all non-essential procedures
like abortions putting it on hold or as
the Democrats tried to shove into their
bill diversity quotas for corporate
boards you know Hospice getting
hospitals masks respirators are making
sure that there's a new being on
retainer as an advisor at Dell this is
something that's really important to
some people trying to make this case for
socialism I think if you actually
observe this objectively you'd have to
take this of the case against
centralized government are kissing the
private sector has stepped up and tried
to fix a quagmire that was created by
government regardless of who's in office
but it also shows us that you know what
there is a finite amount of resources
with government it's ironic to me that
the left they think well this person has
more and so I want to take it they don't
nursing the capitalism free enterprise
is not a zero-sum game that's not just a
piece of the pie you can make more pies
you know it is a fixed pie government
there's only so much money they can take
especially if everybody is unemployed
for indefinitely right there's a limited
amount of resources so let's take into
account the idea that the government
they've had this Russia hoax
investigation going on how many tens of
mail
when you add that up in hundreds of
millions but I don't know billions I'll
have the numbers in front of me the
impeachment sham going on and the CDC
how about the CDC instead of researching
gender pronouns and gun control
statistics you do your job that way
people want to take a steaming crap on
you as an emblem of a systemic
corruption and bureaucracy and
government looking to the private sector
for help there's a fixed amount of
resources and the government seems like
maybe we should be a little more prudent
in where we use our resources so that
we're not caught flat-footed with our
pants down again hmm you know what's in
here it's just water
that's why they call it acting what it
actually smells garlicky there's
something wrong with the water I think
it's going through the icemaker and we
don't have we don't have the baking soda
in the fridge if you liked this video
subscribe hit notifications or just
check back every single day because we
upload a new video every single day this
is actually taken from the full show a
full hour show the way upload every
single Thursday click that right now go
watch the entire show if you don't want
to you don't you don't have to but if
you if you stop by you know just don't
bother me I'm gonna enjoy my garlic
water